the cub starting pitcher brought to you
by
budweiser this buds for you yeah and
advert a guy who kind of pitches a
little bit backwards at times you know
the curveball at 32 and a half percent
there but
it's all set up by the four seam in this
two seam fastballs you know you see and
the 2-2 offering
line drive
and that'll reach the green and
botto's on with a lead off base here
lovato's aboard and that'll bring up
nick castiano's here's a line drive
bottles around second base he's on his
way to third ball is handled out there
they're going to send bottle around and
he will score
as castellanos head first slide into
third and the reds have a one nothing
lead now that's the way you get it going
jesse winker and now the 1-1
center field
should be deep enough to get castillanos
in
and it's two-nothing cincinnati
sacrifice fly rbi jesse winker well the
reds pushed sonny gray back hasn't been
on the mound since the first of the
month
and it was the shortest outing
shortest appearance of his major league
career
last time out it was a tough way to go
and they gave him extra time he says
he's
raring and ready to go and healthy
and when he's been right he's been
amongst the best in all of baseball
gray wines he deals to happen the pitch
is a filthy breaking ball hap swings
right over it and he's down on strike
sonny gray has his first strikeout of
the night there's one away
he does swing and that'll be a base hit
brian goodwin bats now
runner and scoring position payoff to
good one and that is down the right
field line this will plate akiyama
goodwin on his way to second base his
first rbi in red's uniform and it's
three nothing reds
that's rolled into center field
cubs have their second hit
and gray brings it home and the pitch is
a fastball top of the zone strike three
called david bodie
is sonny gray's second strikeout victim
tonight
eight days of rest tonight for sonny
gray
tough play suarez and he will flip nope
he'll hold on to it that was a smart
play to not even try to throw to first
and he thought he might have a
beat on contreras but it's an infield
hit for maven bases loaded with horner
coming up out toward left center that's
going to split the gap here comes
contreras maven
will score it's three to two
nico horner with a big double
and the cubs are back in the game
2-2 count on them done a lot in this
series but he's gonna tie the game here
and he is safe and the cubs have the
lead
great base running by nico horner
it's four to three
a great slide into home plate right here
getting that arm extending getting in
there to give the cubs the lead
that's a baseball play draw in the
infielders a 2-2 count on rizzo
ground ball
bro has to go to first
half is in it's five to three
that will get in there it sounded like
he broke his back he's trying for two
and he is in for the hustle double
[Music]
so cameron mabin at the plate contreras
at third one out in field in the pitch
he lines one base hit down the left
field line coming in is contreras racing
to second base is maven he's turning and
headed for third the throw the slide
safe
and rbi triple for cameron maven and the
cubs extend the lead six to three over
the reds here in the fifth inning
they've been trying to score bottles
gonna get one at second relay late
7-3
third rbi for horner tonight
on the ground and that'll get into right
rizzo's got his second hit and his third
reach
golfed high in the air shallow center
field
and good one
not back to
[Music]
has stepped into the on deck circle for
the cubs swaying and a miss stevenson
does his job
off to the seventh we go
and suarez yanks it fair down the left
field line
and that will kick out into the
left field grass suarez will hang on at
first base
and that'll be a leadoff hit for a eu
genio suarez
could be two
up nope
it was bobbled and then not fielded and
the reds have the first two on now i
think that david ross is going to come
out and probably argue this and say well
didn't he have control of it and he lost
it in the transition
they're going to call him safe at second
base
and ross is saying wait he got one out
right let's take a look right here
vargas bobbles it gives it the bias is
buyers lose it in the
transition from the glove to the hand
obviously he's going for the transfer
but
and he's safe never had control of the
baseball i think is what they probably
determined so a good break for the reds
and akiyama sends a little flare left
center field that'll fall for a hit
around third suarez he's coming home
he'll score throw into second and out at
second base is akiyama i think he slid
past the bag base hit tyler stevenson
and the reds have scored two here in the
eighth it's a two run game
there's a bullet out of the left center
alleyway
it's gonna rest right near the vines
bryant's gonna score
and contreras
has a double
eight to five
hander wick in the seventh i don't know
if that was just because that's what
they wanted if there was an injury they
will turn it game over
cubs win
cubs win eight to five
a comeback victory tonight
and they take two of three and yeah
wilson contreras has to be happy with a
four hit night tonight